[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
or in their home walking down the street
you know we need to be accountable for
what they do
people have goes for drug deals and they
get 99 years this person would never be
able to have kids with never fabulous to
have a wife their mom his mom wakes up
everything Mergen he's not there she
can't call her on the phone she can't
talk to him there is no peace of know
Justin they should have been 25 to 99
and I can just say y'all that this is a
systemic problem this is the problem
black people are not valued in this
country in this city we are tired and we
are gonna rise up we're gonna rise up
and get the system and we're gonna fight
for our right that's right okay we are
tired of being treated like animals and
that we do not matter but today it is a
new day in Dallas there were two mothers
in here today that came here to support
Botham John's mother they we are tired
of getting our children getting just
taken from us this is getting tiring in
these mothers there's a mother in there
crying right she lives right here here
she is she this is what you're doing
you're traumatizing our beauty
traumatising reach Ramat eyes read
trauma side every time we see another
word every time we walk down the street
you ask us why we watch what else can we
do
we're supposed to just live think ahead
ladies can I just walk down the street
we have to march down the street because
we are politicking for our lives we have
to politic and ask for you to give us
indictments for you to kick ass in
protest she would not be charged at all
and we have not ready can we let her
speak to me later speak my name is my
name is Dee crank I am the mother of
Travis crank who was killed in 2017 by
the Arlington police officer named Craig
Roper how many of us does it take to get
justice a man killed 22 people in El
Paso Texas and you want me to understand
that he's mixed up what about my son
what about both of Jed what about
Christian Taylor read about Trayvon
Martin how many of us even going to take
before you understand that our lives my
life is over
what about focus mom where's her justice
every guy who gets a chance to get
freedom after ten years if I stood and
both them and other sons are dead
forever
we did not get justice and this is fair
how many of us is it going to take there
should be another mother after us Tish
should be another person
are we surprised yet we got a murder
conviction but anything they give you
they can take it back you know what I'm
saying I'm not surprised
the system doesn't value us and it never
will it not only speak for the two you
know what I mean that's why we are in
the trenches Fatherhood over hood
Brotherhood over any hood we gonna stand
up for ourselves man [ __ ] this we are
justice we stand for justice we get
together if we don't get together these
officers do not get charged when they
put it through the grand jury is noble
it's got to stop officer should be held
no much more than a citizen should be we
as people I'm speaking of colored people
black people in this country has been
traumatized and victimized by the
injustice in the system this system is
not designed for us it will never work
for us we will never receive the equal
justice that we deserve and all of us
are here we're here today because we
want to make changes ten years it's not
enough both in John's life matter and
when there is no justice it should never
be any peace it should never be we stand
here as a community outraged because we
have saw many times in this courtroom
people who take lives people who do many
things but when it comes to a black
person when it comes to a black person
getting justice in this system this is
what we see continuously ten years many
people say oh yeah we we haven't saw
this before different things of that
nature but is ten years enough for a
life being taken
is it to you is 10 years enough for what
this family has to fill in the gap the
rest of their lives both them was both
them was a uncle a son a brother he was
many things to many people
all I can say is is that I will limit my
words and your guys will see my words in
every full force tonight at 6:30 because
this is what we have to break down we
have to continue to continue to make
sure and we just send our prayers out to
this joint family but we know that this
hurt I heard as a community it's for
this family because we know that this
family is really hurt really hurt why
give them murder conviction give them 10
years that's just a slap in the face of
injustice and at the end of the day hey
we got a we gotta organize so I asked
all the Dallas to come join us at 6:30
at the Fern Crowley
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
both of John's was every placard for
mothers sons Travis
Trayvon Martin was every flecked mother
son he was my son the lady's stunned at
that was my son that's why I'm here I
have a son I had grandsons I have black
granddaughters we need justice if the
table was tired it'll be something
totally different